dans la famille huawei je demande le
fils ben tiens voilà le fils huawei a
officialisé à quelques jours sa gamme p
series regroupant beaucoup de
smartphones et 40 p 40 pro pkr opus mais
également le paie 40 like le paie 40
like
il est là il est sympa et plus 40
injustement je voulais vous en parler
parce qu'il ya plein de choses à dire
sur ce prêt 40 lights est le petit frère
de la famille néanmoins ce smartphone là
apple a tout plein davantage et il est
juste là donc aujourd'hui en faire un
tour de peilz 40 like on va regarder
quel est l'intérêt de ce smartphone est
ce qu'il est fait pour vous on va faire
un tour globale de la question photo
autonomie performance toussa toussa
toussa toussa et bien évidemment à la
fin de la vidéo je donnerai mon retour
complet si vous voulez jouer au jeu des
7 différences vous pouvez jouer avec ces
deux boîtiers 40 like p40 trop puisque a
vraiment très très peu de différence une
différence de taille aps ça vous le
voyez le nom change ici il n'ya pas de
l'aica par contre vous avez dans les
deux cas la galerie et je crois que dans
l'absolu voyez il n'y a pas beaucoup de
différence puisque la vraie différence
elle se situe ici mais la vraie dix ans
si tu lis ici au niveau de la recherche
toi que cette petite couleur vert existe
en vert ou noir et rose
huawei a fait ce choix là pour la partie
appareil photo qui et différenciante
mais dans l'absolu pourquoi pas on a
donc quatre caméras plus un petit flash
est belge et vous les détails et dans
quelques instants
mais si sur la tranche va trouver un
bouton qui sert également de capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui fonctionne
extrêmement via le bouton de volume au
bas et c'est tout en dessous de l'usbc
un micro un haut parleur et une prise
jack de l'autre côté vous avez le tiroir
de cartes sim vous pouvez mettre ici
soit doom nanosims soigne aussi plus
carte micro sd tandis que sur le dessus
et vous avez un micro pour la réduction
de bruit à l'avant votre mission qui
pensant qu'il vient loger votre caméra
de celle fille puis voyez ci n'ont rien
de bien spectaculaire un manteau qui est
un peu plus grand mais dans cette gamme
de prix c'est complètement raisonnable
une prise en main qui est bonne parce
qu'un fan qui est pas très lourd qui
fait 183 g à la vente une dalle ipes
c'est du lcd de 6,4 pouces diagonale ça
c'est un des points forts de ce
smartphone parce qu'il ya quand même un
écran qui relativement haut rang full hd
+ 2310 pas 1080 pixels à 398 xl par
pouce la modification je vous conseille
de faire c'est de venir dans les
paramètres c'est exactement la même
chose que j'ai fait dans le pkr en pro
vous allez dans votre mode et
température de couleurs par défaut que
c'est en couleurs vives moi je vous
invite quand même à vous mettre en
couleur normale elle est poussée en
chaude ça bien jauni à l'écran et c'est
beaucoup plus agréable
et oui forcément faut penser à vos yeux
et
bien les protéger on a donc un
smartphone qui est complètement optimisé
pour la partie multimédia que ça pour me
regarder des séries des films tout ce
que vous voulez mais c'est vrai sur
youtube fr vous avez haut parleur mono
son côté que ce coup franc puissant avec
un stack qui est quand même plutôt pas
mal de voir qu'on a un petit haut
parleur il développe des graves et comme
je le disais si vous n'allez plus vous
avez si votre prise jack
comment mettre à bénéficier de la
meilleure qualité audio et je veux
savoir vous avez également du bluetooth
5.0 si vous voulez utiliser un casque
sans fil pour jouer pour s'amuser faire
tout ce que vous voulez avec des verbes
du premier groupe en est bien vous
pouvez y aller parce que ça fera
franchement la sphère côté performances
vous avez derrière un kirin 810 si j'y
garde ram 128 go de stockage que vous
pouvez monter grâce à une carte microsd
jusqu'à 256 giga pour de l' usage
courant ça ira parfaitement bien
attention vous pouvez pas faire tourner
si tous les jeux est ce que vous n'avez
pas non plus le processeur le plus haut
de gamme si vous voulez aller beaucoup
plus haut niveau l'expérience vous en
douterez il faudra aller sur le cac40
pro et sur le cac40 mais je dirais qu
une façon un peu plus générales vous n'a
pas retourné beaucoup de jeu de la
galerie eh bien vous avez de quoi faire
avec ce smartphone et les textures à
toulouse a vu le score de 289 1714 en
fonction de vos usages vous allez le
garder un jour et demi vous avez une
grosse batterie derrière de 4200
millions terreur mais je dirais que là
où est le point le plus fort de ce
smartphone
c'est pas tant la batterie qui est quand
même vraiment bien c'est surtout la
question de la charge puisque oui si
vous avez de la superbe charge 40 watts
qui vous permet de recharger extrêmement
rapidement 2-0 à 70 % en seulement 30
minutes partie logicielle autour d' ici
sur emotion uac 10.0.1 basé sur
l'android 10 si vous connaissez monsieur
new wave ou ça vous n'avez pas de
tiroirs d'application tout se situe ici
votre tour vos apps vous pouvez lire
groupe est bien évidemment il ya une
belle amélioration et un beau travail
qui a été fait là dessus et notamment au
niveau des paramètres tout est bien
regroupé on a vraiment gagné en
lisibilité
vous le savez s'il n'y a pas de pelé
store mais par contre vous avez la
galerie d'huawei la bière guen j'en ai
déjà parlé dans une autre vidéo que je
vous invite à aller visionner pour
savoir comment elle fonctionne ce que
vous pouvez avoir quelles sont les
applications qui tournent dessus et
surtout comment récupérer les
applications les données les contacts
les photos de votre ancien smartphone
pour les transférer directement sans
votre nouveau smartphone de huawei vous
explique aussi comment trouver toutes
vos applications et d'utiliser très
facilement là dessus donc vous invite à
aller jeter un coup d'oeil à cette vidéo
vous avez donc quatre capteurs photo là
rien d'autres smartphones le capteur ou
à droite
c'est votre capteur principal c'est un
grand temps de 46 mégapixels tour à f
1.8 qui vous sortira des photos en 12
mégapixels vous avez en dessous et si un
nul
sa grand tante de 8 mégapixels touvre f
2.4 en bas à gauche était la caméra pour
la macro de 2 mégapixels et ouvre à f
2.4 tandis qu'en haut à gauche c'est
d'une caméra qui est là pour mode
portrait pour les faits évoqués de 2
mégapixels couvre également à f 2.4
tandis qu'elle avançait la caméra de 5
mégapixels
bref 2.0 au niveau software ça fait le
taff vous avez bien évidemment et c'est
un des gros points forts de m'angoisser
de l'intelligence artificielle pour
venir faire des photos toujours plus
intelligente grâce à la reconnaissance
de scène
évidemment en mode photo mode portrait
clichés nocturne objectif
ar vous y retrouve également avec de la
vidéo ici par contre vous ne filmez
quand 1080 pas de kafka et à proposer
plein modes différents prora lentille
panoramique ouverture le mode macro time
lapse image dynamique document on peut
faire quand même pas mal de choses on va
regarder les photos du p 40 light
premières photos prises avec le capteur
principal la colorimétrie est assez
juste on voit bien la rose au milieu le
détail et banques et ça fonctionne
deuxième photo prise avec l'ultra 30 ans
dont va qu'on n'a pas tout à fait la
même colorimétrie c'est légèrement plus
pâle mais ça me paraît pas anormale sur
un smartphone de ce tarif là on continue
ici avec un zoom x 2 il fait franchement
le boulot pour max un zoom numérique et
un zoom optique et ensuite on arrive
jusqu'au x 6 ces mois exceptionnels
s'est plus laissée ya plus de bruit mais
ça me paraît normal dans cette gamme de
tarifs là capteur principal
ultra-grand-angle x 2 x 6 beaucoup de
bruit capteur principal
ultra-grand-angle x 2 x 6 l'homme et
serait photos prises avec le mode
portrait chiens peu dubitatif
il ya certains endroits où ça marche
très bien notamment envoyé sur la main
ici où les contours sont quand même bien
fait sur le puits à tendance un petit
peu à se perdre ici les cheveux vont
bien sauf toute cette partie là qui est
flou qui n'a pas réussi à repérer entre
les doigts ça va à peu près vu le
processeur et vu qu'on n'a pas de caméra
teuf et rendu me paraissent pas anormaux
la caméra de cette lui donne un rendu
qui franchement correct il en arrive sur
la macro alors moi la macro je suis
jamais bienbienbien fans sur les
smartphones c'est pas trop mal lorsque
vous avez beaucoup de lumière tout de
suite c'est beaucoup plus lisse et
s'ébruiter si vous aimez ça pourquoi pas
mais moi je ne suis pas particulièrement
fan sur la photo du lycée un smartphone
qui est pas particulièrement bon et
c'est relativement normal si vous voulez
aller loin au niveau soutenu il faut
aller sur le paie 40 pro le détail dont
le retrouve part de son ex pôle ont tenu
à la main autant la vision de lumière
est pas mauvaise autant vu qu'on a
aucune stabilisation optique mais tout
de suite c'est un peu flou un smartphone
que vous pouvez déverrouiller de
différentes manières via capteur
d'empreinte digitale via facebook qui
dérouille extrêmement rapidement un
smartphone qui contrairement à ses
grands frères il n'a pas de 5 g ici vous
avez la 4g de la 3g et du sii vraiment
n'y a pas de réseau mais c'est vrai
pour début 2010 ça me paraît quand même
normal mais par contre ici vous avez dû
à l'excès un smartphone qui est
disponible dès maintenant vous pouvez
commander ailleurs je vous dis un lien
en bas dans la description qui est dispo
au tarif normal de ces noté l'un noir
sur blanc 329 euros 99 et là vous avez
une offre de reprise sur le site de rwe
vous trouvez à 279 euros 99
voilà pour toutes les informations sur
ce p 40 light à qui s'adresse-t-il ça
c'est un smartphone qui reste sur les
visages un peu standard un grand écran
pour le visionnage multimédia vous avez
de la performance mais pas trop où je
n'ai donc pas pouvoir profiter des jeux
les plus gourmands par contre je dirais
que beaucoup d'application et beaucoup
de jeu de la galerie pourront tourner
dessus donc si vous souhaitez vous
divertir vous aurez vraiment de quoi
faire surtout avec ce grand écran ça
c'est extrêmement plaisant le son est de
qualité donc le côté multimédia que ce
soit au casque de soit directement sur
votre smartphone pour moi là dessus ils
cochent les casiers aucun problème la
partie photo fonctionne surtout au
niveau du capteur principal avec
derrière pour le travail logiciels qui
est fait par oui et notamment grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle l'autonomie
est plutôt bonne c'est donc un
smartphone qui saura répondre aux trois
quarts des usages si vous voulez un
smartphone équilibré qui fait le taff
découvre beaucoup d'usagers sans aller
trop loin et bien on a vu le paie 40
like vraiment il fait pour vous dites
moi vous maintenant ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire comment
vous trouvez se paie 40 light déjà d'un
point de vue purement esthétique est ce
que vous aimez le design qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ce module photo qui fait
comme ça marche ou ça va pas mal ça
assez efficace le côté vert comme sa
femme un peu émeraude je vous ça apporte
quelque chose
j'attends donc de lire vos commentaires
juste en bas et sur celle de rendez vous
dès demain pour continuer à part été
créés ou dans ma des bisous à demain
ciao
[Musique]